hey what do you think my dream means
probably nothing
sounds really dumb I love your hat
what's the thickest yarmulke I've ever
seen thanks dude it's like there's no
place for Islam in America well for you
there is for Brownville since it's worse
than ever even in Black Panther there's
a Muslim terrorist going what I hate
really yeah
locusts movie of the year and there's
still a Muslim terrorist with an ak-47
going we would kill the girls what lie
he did it's better than when they go
unlock bomb and then kill everyone
it's Allah ho Akbar just get it right if
you're gonna disgrace the culture
completely well guess what
I'll be your white Ally whatever you
need I got your back pay for this meal
no really thank you my how I
[Music]
dog
hello whose dog is this Hey
come on hey do you know whose dog this
is no but it would suck if anything were
to happen to it
hey it's Ramadan do you want some food
ramen Abba dumb you man you
sit up there in that shitty tower with
your clothes made by child slaves
well I sit here and begging the
hot Sun dude I gave you your clothing
you're wearing my clothing yeah you
think I like this it's almost
there's a great need right no she just
appeared in my bedroom this morning
crazy funny yeah where are you guys off
to you now oh we're going to work I
deliver food for a living you deliver
food hmm oh my god you were
loser deal with a capital u it's almost
maybe she just followed someone in the
front door and then came to your door
cuz she smelled food and then your
neighbour let her in thinking it was
yours maybe or maybe she's a miracle dog
because she's the dog from my dream she
likes doing that a lot yeah she's horny
I mean I have to tell you something
what's up my parents are trying to set
me up wait on a date yeah
I mean a really long date like one where
we get married
wait an arranged marriage is that even
legal I mean I could say no legally but
my parents would kill me
perfect that's comment please I know
this sucks but I have to tell you that
who is it just a stupid doctor he's a
doctor yeah he probably won't even have
time for me he's always working or
buying cars and he sends me these
selfies
oh my god he's so creepy thanks thanks a
lot maybe you should go
[Music]